very look you want to fight dylan danis
no no no i'm not talking about fighting
this [ __ ] no i'm not going i'm talking
about i'm talking about in the gym live
so i'm not talking about what was your
max bench
475 500 that's more than me oh 425 what
was your dead
bro i mean i could probably do 750 right
now oh yeah jesus christ he's the
strongest strongest that's just [ __ ]
he's super that's crazy strong
damn jim i i work out 750 yeah
you've been living away since elementary
well yeah since i was 15.
cause some guys are bodybuilders and
aren't necessarily that's what i'm
saying you're talking about me fighting
this [ __ ] dylan danis kid and i talk
[ __ ] to him on the internet he never
pulled up to my gym i know but you're
gonna hear from him now cool i mean he
jumps in my live all the time and talks
[ __ ] i said come here's my address
this is where i want to go dylan that
you cannot fight dillon downstairs grabs
you if he grabs you it's going to be bad
you want me to facetime right now how
much is going on he's 190.
and he's really really good jiu-jitsu is
yeah you'll get caught in some [ __ ] i
promise i promise you you're gonna get
choked out i i promise you you know in a
street fight
i'm not talking about doing jiu jitsu
against this guy do you know jujitsu i
mean i've done a little bit i don't know
it like he knows it obviously he says
he's 170 right here yeah but he's he
walks around 185. he's not going to it's
not fair because he don't do traditions
that's why i don't want him to try to
fight but we all know though when you
when you're a black belt i don't care
what black belt you are when you start
getting [ __ ] punched in the face you
become a white belt real fast this is
all i'm saying he's made his career off
of [ __ ] proven black belts and white
belts real quick
he's on my blue belt
is that you is you wrestling at the ufc
institute on your uh ig yeah bring that
up gin
critique is uh honestly yeah ig all
right yeah that's all you're right do
you wrestle in high school no no i
didn't wrestle in high school but
bradley's [ __ ] athletic i'm sure
you're athletic but you know what i'm
saying i want to wrestle you and see if
i'm stronger than you because yeah i'd
love you because you're you're strongly
lifting weights i can't lift weights
[ __ ]
yeah yeah this what is this no look
bradley's got it you got a great body
and you're athletic as [ __ ] but i mean
you look very good
but i don't think scroll down scroll
down
i just think i just think that this is a
different thing oh that when i'm
wrestling steve you mean yeah there's
two tooth go up
go out it's right there on the right
rather if you go just just roll through
the way
15 220 here
this guy let's not cut your hair like
that ever again yeah okay who is steve
what does he do it's my buddy steve
steve will do that yeah steve will do it
they all know steve will do he's the
regular guy right now yeah
yeah
oh he's going for the second day yeah
you're gonna i don't know
but i'm not wrestling again i wouldn't
be arresting the guy you act like i
would just try to wrestle him right
because now you're going to try to stand
no steve get out of there steve steve
get out of there man
nice side choke now watch this
yeah i mean do you think you can tap joe
rogan
tap joe rogan i don't know i i don't
think so i don't think so
talking about me tap him out no i don't
know i'm not talking about rolling
you're you never like you were like the
ant chris
damn yeah i i never i never um i never
loved jiu jitsu i didn't love it i
didn't like it i didn't i i just didn't
like gravitate towards it i didn't i
didn't like i'm because i'm i'm low-key
a germ freak and he rode around with
sweaty ass dudes i've had dudes sweating
my mouth and [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that i i
stopped liking i had rampant i'm had uh
rashad rubs big ass dick on my face
i was like bro what are you doing yeah
it happens i used to train with tito and
he's always one of those those shorts
with the flames on it yeah he don't wear
underwear bro and he got a long scrotum
and one time
it teabagged me bro and i was like done
i'm like
i'm telling you the most
erotic thing ever happened he was rashad
he was a spandex yeah man you have a cup
on i don't want to say anything like
let's roll it yeah no doubt and then he
went to you know like that north south
which is already kind of weird and it
just
did
did you tap out from there or did you
yarn
yeah she's a baddie
yeah so dylan wants to fight you you're
saying he just talks he wants to fight
everybody
but here's the thing bradley wants a
fight he like he's asked me like he
wants me to find him a fight oh you want
to fight i want an mma fight though i
don't want to box
hey what do we do why don't we do this
thing with you
we can do it for the we can do it for
like a podcast we do it for a show so my
buddy rich chow he does this whole wimps
to warrior they train you they come in
they put you in a gym they train you for
six to eight weeks and they schedule you
a fight and they make it like a charity
event it's a big deal
can i go ahead all right i'm sorry
here's the problem so from wimps to
warriors i don't know who they've had on
that okay the issue is bradley is very
successful in his space yeah he wants
someone of equal clout which is very
hard to find he's very very in his face
you know i i get what you're saying so
maybe maybe we maybe find another
fighter you know what i'm saying yeah
maybe we find another maybe we'll find
another like top level youtube guy to
[ __ ] hey you guys both do it there's
not many though yeah but let's do dylan
davis is he i love a youtuber no but
he's got a little bit of clout who dylan
dylan don't get you [ __ ] up brother
not right now obviously but at some
point i would i want i want to say
that's the long beach
i'll do
i think brennan is being tight-lipped
right now but i think brennan would
steer you away from dylan dennis but see
here but but i think i think you could
find him another youtuber a little bit
100 you can find somebody
bradley is athletic and
strongly hey hey you heard his numbers
hey listen to mine hey look at me over
here i know that
and i see your i see what you're
you always know what brendan's [ __ ]
around because he'll start doing this
with his face
it'll be fun
but brendan knows he's like just [ __ ]
around and you do too hey and you're a
[ __ ] bad guy and you're a bad i am a
bad guy i'm a bad guy because you're
both bad guys because you're like this
yeah
yeah yeah
do it you know what my only thing is is
he like he won't like just [ __ ] around
like he'll train for sure he will
i'm sure he will and i like this guy and
he's not a he's a he's got a gym he's a
good guy he has dj and i i'm i'm a
little protective over you frankly i
appreciate it i happen to i i
i don't want to see you
do something silly because it's a it's a
language you're not you don't he's very
fluent in that language and you will
make a mistake like give him your ankle
and then you're not talking about well
for about nine months on your knee
that's what dylan dance can do to you i
promise
and then your legs go from being able to
squat 700 or something to like all of a
sudden
yeah it's not worth it something bad
will happen without like flex on that
one
numbers though man my bad side bradley
just smash him bro smash him
i'm your friend they're not bradley
when a civilian
says i want to fight that guy fighters
go like this they go get it
you're getting there you're right now
you're getting the head
and they're going see what happens
because they know but like i understand
that you're a big strong guy so you're
confident
it's like a d1 lacrosse player who says
i want to fight that guy who can who can
and then he
it's just different it's a different
language right different sport different
sport you're very very strong because
that's your bradley go ahead